joining us now here on the rich eisen
show is one of our favorites we figured
with coach k announcing his retirement
let's get uh jay bilas here on the rich
eisen show from the worldwide leader in
sports and
duke university alum how are you jay
bilas
i am doing great rich thanks for having
me great to be with you again i
appreciate that
um i'll ask you first off we were
nervous about booking this kid from
connecticut he's thrown four straight
no-hitters jay
and he starts tomorrow he hasn't given
up he hasn't given up a hit since the
day before the nfl draft
in late april you know but he said yes i
mean what do you think that show is for
this kid
to say sure i'll talk about what else
what do you think that he doesn't
believe in the unwritten rules of
baseball where you're not supposed to
mention no hitter
you gotta pretend that things don't
happen uh while they're happening
i never really understood that but
nobody would talk to the pitcher in the
dugout while a no-hitter was going on
that that seemed a little awkward
were you ever superstitious playing at
all jay did you ever
yeah yeah i was i was uh if i didn't
play well i wouldn't wear the same pair
of shoes again that's why i have about a
thousand pairs of shoes
is that what happened to zion a couple
years ago with duke so what happened
yeah 30 seconds into the game he knew it
wasn't going to go
well so he just decided to change his
shoes and change his knee
blows out just blow the whole thing out
uh i did that i did that game actually
and when it happened uh you know like
president obama was there and spike lee
and all these guys and
you know i was like is this duke
carolina or laker game when you know
show the showtime lakers were playing
and uh i've never seen the air come out
of a building like it did when that shoe
popped
so what's it gonna be like in that
building when it's coach k's final
season
next year what do you think that's going
to be like jake yeah i i mean electric
is uh is going to be an understatement
and i already got
uh you know my wife and i have season
tickets there
at duke and cameron and the reason we
got him was i got tired of calling the
basketball office begging for tickets
when a friend of mine wanted to go
right so we just bit the bullet and
bottom but my as soon as coach k
announced his retirement both my
daughter and my son said can we go
like don't give the tickets away and
we're like really um they're going on
ebay by the way
yeah it's gonna be you know it's gonna
be an odd feeling obviously it'll it'll
certainly be a celebration
uh in so many respects but uh
uh even though that intellectually you
knew that this time was coming he's 74
years old they'll be 75
in february um you know he's defied
everything i
i always figured that that he would he
would quit when his hair turned color
but
that hasn't happened yet so i think he
should keep going
so why do you think now i know he's been
talking about it but i'll i'll i'll give
you
um the floor on your two cents as to why
now why
why just this week too to make that
announcement
well why now it's it it's stage of life
um
you know at age 74 i mean when when when
you and i were kids it was unfathomable
that that this many coaches would coach
into their 70s i mean when
i grew up in los angeles and when john
wouldn't quit and the uh the 75
final four he announced his retirement
he was 65 and and i thought he was you
know older than
uh than the pyramids and now you got
guys you know 10 years older than him
still going and you know jim beehive at
syracuse is saying well he's not even
close
to quitting so um uh you know it
because they've gone so long and have
been so healthy and so effective
uh it seems like it you know he could
keep going but
i don't think it has anything to do with
uh you know the state of the game
or the transfer report all this nonsense
and and not just coach k but i've kind
of pushed back on that without with all
these coaches and ads when people are
saying well you know everything's
changing so much
and they can't stand it if they were all
40 years old making this kind of money
they'd figure it out
and there's been tremendous change in
the times that coach k
has been been coaching and he's adapted
to all of it he could adapt to this it's
just his stage of life he's got
grandkids
uh his wife uh mickey who's a wonderful
lady you know i'm sure she'd like to
to have a more normal life where they're
they're not uh
a slave to the recruiting calendar and
all that stuff uh as they enter their
their their golden years
on into the future so so i think it's
more that than anything else i i
i honestly uh rich have been amazed
that that's the the most amazing thing
to me about coach k
among the the many amazing things is
that his enthusiasm for his job has
never waned
and his energy for it and and i i i
joked about it recently but i i think
it's actually a fair analogy i kind of
called him the ultimate sherpa
because every year he takes a different
group up to the uh up to the everest and
he never gets tired of setting up base
camp
and making sure everybody's got what
they need and then guiding them up the
mountain and trying to get to the summit
it's a different trip every time for him
and he could say
been there done that and and sort of
mail it in
and that's sort of what older people
tend to do is they kind of get tired of
the day-to-day of it and he's never
gotten tired of it
jay bell is here on the rich eisen show
when'd you first meet him when did he
first cross
your radar screen and you're you're 17
years old
and i had just played in uh in a thing
called
the equivalent of five star and the west
coast i played the sports world
superstar camp and i made the all-star
team and i got
a call from duke uh from one of their
assistants named chuck swenson
and after that it followed up for from a
call from from mike schuszewski and i
had never heard the name i didn't know
who he was
and i had heard of duke because they
played in the 1978 championship game
against kentucky but i didn't know where
duke was
uh if you had said it's in north
carolina that wouldn't have registered
with a california kid
pre-internet and uh and i did not have a
great relationship with my high school
coach so when i was being recruited
all that mattered to me was who i was
going to play for what school i went to
was of
you know secondary tertiary concern and
so
i liked him the best um i came down to
four coaches i came down to ted owens at
kansas
loot olson at iowa and jim beyheim at
syracuse
and uh and coach k was the least well
known least accomplished
uh had the least amount of time in and i
just knew
like he was the right guy for me i
didn't know at the time
you know i couldn't wrap my head around
he'd be there 42 years
you know and and be considered the
greatest you know the great maybe the
greatest coach ever
and all that stuff but i knew he was i
knew he was great
and i knew he was the best for me so
what made him so great
i mean we know what his legacy is going
to be but what what
what what was the secret sauce for him
for 42 years to do it the way that he
did it
and to do it uh at duke what was
what what's the difference based on your
your travels and your work that you've
done
for all these years at espn as well what
what do you got for me on that front
jack he he has a an amazing ability to
engender trust and that that was really
what got me was i trusted him right away
uh as a high school kid and uh and he
was unfailingly honest and didn't always
tell you what you wanted to hear
honest and you know when he was
recruiting me
um you know every every coach that
recruited against him said now you
realize if you go to duke he's going to
make you play center for four years
that's not your position
and i brought that up to him and i said
everybody's telling me you're gonna make
me play center and he said well i will
for a year
uh but after that i'll recruit a big guy
and and move you back to your your
natural spot and and you know i i
figured that most guys wouldn't admit
that that was
that was going to be the case and it
wound up you know i want a plane center
for four years
it never bothered me um those guys were
right but but he did recruit recruit
other guys but
um it was i i never would have made
another decision and as much as i loved
lewd olsen and
beyheim and uh and coach owens uh and
revered those guys
um i never i've never second guessed the
decision
even when he was calling me the biggest
wimp that had ever lived and how could i
not get that rebound and
uh you know i can't believe you're that
slow stuff like that i never second
guessed it
so he would be demanding and tough like
that so you don't think that uh
the 21st century athlete um might
blush um or not appreciate that sort of
hard coaching i mean
do you you don't change he's changed
that and i'll give you an example so
this was i can't remember the year
whether it's 2009 or whatever
i was at duke to see practice and uh and
he
uh coach k was going to take the team in
and watch film and he looked at me on
the sidelines says why do you come in
sit in the locker room watch film with
us
so i sat in the back and and i started
to get it's almost like i was getting
vietnam flashbacks because he was
running something back and i was going
okay
mason plumley's about to get it and i
was going all right this was me
and i needed therapy after after the
film sessions
and he stopped the film and i was
expecting okay here comes fire and
brimstone and wrath of god except now
he's actually considered a god
and uh and he he said in in just a
normal tone of voice he said mason i've
never had a good player do this
and if you want to be a good player you
better not be doing this again
and and it was so effective um but but
it didn't beat him up
and uh and i i thought okay this guy is
is on a different level now
uh because uh you know i i needed to
wear a flak jacket and a helmet during
uh
during a film session when i played for
him and rightfully so because uh you
know he would he
it was i put it on a tee for him to be
able to go after me but
but he certainly changed the way he's
done things and adapted to
things but his his ability to deliver a
message and have it received and acted
upon
now like he's he's so much of a better
coach now than he was when i played for
him and i don't say that uh to be
negative or to to
you know in any jealousy it's just that
that he keeps getting better
and he's better i think he'll be better
next year than he was last year and
uh i guess that's the way you you expect
it to be when you really think about it
but it's not the norm you know you don't
see that stuff all the time and
and he's a he's a next level thinker um
he
he thinks relationships he he jumps on
top of
every issue at the very beginning before
it becomes a bigger one
and uh and that's not true of everyone
like he he he goes after the team when
they're winning too
uh basically saying hey look you know we
might have won this game but this isn't
going to win
later so we need to correct this and
we've had slippage here we've done this
where
truthfully a lot of coaches wouldn't do
that because they wouldn't want to rock
a winning boat
jay bilas a couple more minutes left
with him right here from espn and of
course a long time
duke university alum and one of coach
k's first
uh right here on the rich eisen show so
we all knew this day would come clearly
uh father time uh does not stand still
and the successor uh hand-picked is john
shire
um is this the type of conduit you
envisioned
that coach k would would leave the
program in the hands of
what can you tell me on that front i
don't know what i envision
envision rich because you know you get
asked that question i got asked that
question a lot before this about who's
the next guy
and and the truthful answer was i don't
know and to me
you know the decision was was not only
when uh the difficulty of the decision
was how
like do you do it at the end of a year
and just not coach the following year
or do you do it like like he's done it
here this is an unusual way to do it uh
because it's an unusual situation or do
you do it like dean smith did right
right before the following season and
then
and then the university has to take an
assistant you don't know i i didn't know
it's
it's a crazy sort of decision to have to
make
given the gravity of it i mean i think
it's going to be the hardest act to
follow in the history of
at least college sports and i can't
think of anybody else that's at a 35
year run with this sort of sustained
excellence but
john shire is an outstanding young coach
and uh
he's technically skilled uh he
understands what he's getting into
and i think he is more than capable of
doing this and doing it
at the highest level so i have i'm a
believer i have no issue with with uh
with john um uh being the next choice
uh i don't know how other people feel
but um i think he's a terrific choice
and the fact that coach k
believes in him so much uh uh should
give everybody
uh a really good feeling about it
because uh of the times he's been wrong
recruiting me being the the the one um
he hasn't been wrong very often and i
don't think he's wrong here
how do you think coach k is going to be
as a retiree like what do you think he's
going to
do will he totally disappear will he
show up at a game will he
what do you think his his uh his years
as a
former coach will be i would say he'll
be
uh respectfully present and
in a dignified way like i don't think
he's going anywhere and i think we're
going to see a lot of him and i hope
that's the case
but uh but i i i think he'll handle it
in a wonderful way
i'm just frankly i you know just being
completely honest
i don't know how to handle things right
now you know when you announce the
retirement
do i buy him a gift now or do i wait
and i don't i don't really know i i'm
sure his answer is going to be
you idiot it's two gifts it's now and
later yes
um so i and i don't know what people are
going to give them i think rocking
chairs before the game are
kind of antiquated and you don't need to
go there uh i'm sure a
nice case of wine or something like that
he would appreciate
he claims to do a lot of gardening maybe
some gardening tools or some seeds or
something
um but i can't i'm gonna have to think
of a good gift and then i have to think
of uh
you know how many am i gonna get but
i'll tell you rich that the the
there's a a lot of discord among the
former players right now
about how thoughtless coach k has been
in announcing it now
yes because a lot of us are playing in
our member guest golf tournaments
and gerald henderson has his club
championship this weekend i'm playing
a member guest right now i think i heard
somebody yeah we have to
we have to take time to do interviews
and uh you know talk about how great he
is when we're really should be on the
range yeah working on our
working on our game and uh you know it's
been kind of thoughtless frankly so he's
he's not perfect he's great but he's not
perfect
also a very smart fun passive-aggressive
way to say that you're done with this
interview go hit him straight jake
[Laughter]
appreciate it hey rich i've got dave
feldman the former ufc
colleague of yours is my guest and the
member guest
and he has graced me with every time he
hits a good shot
he turns around and says you're welcome
yeah that sounds like feldie send my
best to him
thanks joe well take care brother you
guys jay billis
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here